it's the last day of design week but
that's okay we'll never stop designing
around here but we have a teacher who
turned into a total tick-tock viral
sensation with over five million
followers okay i have like two and it
took me months to get that so here's
some perspective she most recently went
viral for secretly renovating her entire
house where her husband was deployed and
then she let the world follow along as
she did it you gotta see this because
she did not hire someone she did it
herself please welcome corey bosco hi
corey oh
hi
thank you for having me
thank you so much for coming onto our
show and what was the tick tock that
changed everything for you and made you
take the leap and go i'm gonna quit my
job and become a content creator
so from the very first post um it was
during the pandemic the kids were like
mom look at tick tock so it got me
hooked on tick tock and then i realized
that it wasn't just dancing it was
people showing their house designs and
that sort of thing so i showed the very
first tick tock which was um of like
kind of a view of the kitchen going out
to our living room and then showing our
beautiful outdoor um view which is of
the intercoastal here in florida and
so the kids were all ecstatic mom look
at how many views it's getting and i
think he got like 2.2 million views and
i think from then on i was completely
hooked
and you know as a teacher i was you know
teaching to inspire people and now with
this platform
i'm able to inspire people on a
completely different level now with five
million people um and teaching them diys
and just showing other women too that
they can do it and i took the leap and
figured might as well might as well you
know keep on riding this journey while i
can i love that you just went for it i
know you decided not to renovate just
one room not two rooms you did the
entire house while your husband was
deployed what made it danny vinnie was
old winnie
i did
so at the beginning i was planning on
just doing the bathroom i had um been
accepted into the jeffree court
renovation challenge and at that time
benny and i were going to do that
ourselves and then he got his orders to
be activated for the year and so instead
of saying no i'm not going to do it
anymore i decided to go ahead and go
through with it and i figured why stop
now um so i went from the bathroom and
then to a coffee bar to the kitchen to
the laundry room making a fifth bedroom
doing the other kids bedrooms so it
definitely uh was something that just
kind of got me hooked and the support
and you know motivation through social
media has been crazy
it's just amazing to watch you in action
yeah and we got to get a glimpse of
vinnie's reaction when he got home
but you saved one big one the reaction
exclusively for you oh my god please
tell us about it thank you for doing
that
so this is his favorite project for the
entire house thank you so much for
sharing this with us
of course
i i don't even know what to say i
don't even know what to say right now
and then this used to be our bathroom
right
that looks so good in here i love how
it's seamless you know it is
this is freaking
i'm absolutely speechless god i
i love you
i love you i really do
i am so proud of you
oh
minnie
[Applause]
i love you i'm so proud of you
so before you go can you give us one tip
to any of any future renovators out
there thinking about dipping our toe
into the diy pool what would you
recommend how should we start
i always suggest just starting small
finding one thing you're wanting to do
whether it's an accent wall building an
end table something and the amount of
videos that are out there for you to
learn how to do these things with
youtube is is insane so i mean go and
watch a bunch of videos on you know how
to make this certain end table find the
tools that you're going to need purchase
the tools just for that project and you
know go in there dive in and learn as
you go you're going to make mistakes i
still am making mistakes every day but
that's how you learn then you know
you'll learn for your next project too
and you'll just get better with time
speaking of the next project corey would
you ever be willing to come here to new
york and do a design segment with us
yes absolutely all right
thank you
i want to work with you i want to learn
from you you are totally my hero
everybody go to corey's tick-tock and be
as inspired
as we all are here at the show and um
thank you corey thank you so much for
sharing that with us
[Music]
you